photography on congressman morris mo
udall who served as the democratic
representative from arizona's second
district from 1961 to 1991.
they'll begin their discussion tonight
at 9 10 eastern 6 10 pm pacific
next a september 1989 encore book notes
interview with harrison salisbury
pulitzer prize-winning journalist and
author of tiananmen diary 13 days in
june
it's his eyewitness account of the
events during the chinese government's
crackdown of the student-led protests in
1989
it's about an hour
harrison salisbury in your new book
tiananmen diary 13 days in june
you write that
maybe
the ch a chinese leader's call for the
elimination of chopsticks or the
replacement of the knife and fork
may have caused this whole thing explain
that well it's a long train of
circumstances but
you're talking about who you're back who
was the general secretary of the
communist party
and a bullied man a man with a brilliant
mind and
flashing new ideas all the time i spent
some time with him and it's great was
great fun to be with him because he
spoke his mind whatever came into it and
it was one of those minds that ranges
over all possible subjects
great reader
in having things translated into chinese
and one day
it must have popped into his mind or
maybe even thinking of it for some time
in the course of a speech he said it was
time for china
to abandon chopsticks
uh they were in sanitary they're
old-fashioned they're a symbol of the
old china
and take up the knife and fork
well
it caused a furore in china and even
outside of china many of you what's the
man talking about chopsticks or the
essence of china
in china
it was used against him politically
what kind of a man is he how can he be
the leader of the communist party when
he wants china to throw away his
chopsticks and start using
knives and forks it just shows you said
his critics that he's not ready to be
trusted he isn't he isn't stable no
stable leader he
would come up with something like that
well
since huyabang was already under attack
for innovation for being a progressive
and one thing or another this
turned out to be a very valuable
political weapon used against him
and it played a role in his downfall
when he was dismissed
by deng xiaoping
after many students were demonstrating
in tiananmen square in support of reform
and more progress and a dialogue all the
things which huyabang stood for
and this was then put together
huyabang the anti-chopstick man huia
bang
who
caters to the students
get rid of him and indeed
he was dismissed and he went into
retirement
and on the 15th of april of this year
he died
and the students who had never forgotten
him and who still thought of him as
their champion even if he was against
chopsticks uh went into the streets
first of all they started demonstrating
in beijing university and then they
marched up once again to chiang min
square and that's how this whole
critical episode of the lengthy
demonstrations and the
eventually ended by the army being
brought into the square on the third and
fourth of june that's how it all began
and what was his position in china and
and when was he in that position
he was the
general secretary of the communist party
uh under uh deng xiaoping and he was
appointed general secretary
i believe i'm not absolutely sure but i
think it must have been
about sometime in the early 80s
he had been leader of the communist
youth organization he'd been a
an ally of deng xiaoping from the very
earliest times
when dung
fell during the cultural revolution and
was put in into protective custody and
in jail and paraded around with a dunce
cap on his head huya bang suffered
exactly the same fate and the dung
regarded him as a very reliable very
able ally put enormous
tasks before him and dung's choice was
right he was a very interesting and able
man
but dunn
saddled him with responsibility for many
of the defects
that had appeared in his administration
and that was what is that's how he came
to fall from power did you know him i
did indeed i i
one of the most delightful evenings i
ever spent i spent
with uh who you buying first of all had
a long formal interview and then he
invited me and my wife
a couple other people to dinner in
zhang nang high the leadership compound
the place which uh was the center of so
much activity during the uh gentlemen
affair and we
we had
what he called
an american dinner
it wasn't an american dinner at all it
began with escargot
i was very proud of i've served with the
proper
french
tools for eating snails
we had a
a a
marvelous
filet mignon
we had french pastries it was a french
meal really but he kept calling it an
american meal it was he was determined
to show us that that he was
moving into the western world it was a
symbolic meal
no one he had not invited any of the
diplomats or anybody like that
to dinner with him and we were the first
ones
to come and have dinner with huyabang
and he deliberately staged this occasion
to show how western he was this was the
kind of of style that he wanted to bring
into china it fit in with his attack on
chopsticks incidentally it was served by
waitresses who were very smart and very
chic at a time when there was no such
thing in china they wore the traditional
uh chinese gowns sort of plum colored
with the slit skirt right up to the knee
and i noticed one of these
rather lovely young ladies kept sitting
standing behind who you bang and i
couldn't understand why until i saw
how excited he got in his conversation
as he got excited he kept moving forward
on his chair further and further and
more and more animated until you thought
he might just leap into the air
and perhaps he has on some occasions
anyway she was there to be sure that he
got back into his seat and didn't fall
on the floor
and i thought it was a wise precaution
it's one of the most interesting
evenings i've ever had
he got onto all kinds of subjects and
one of the things he asked me on that
occasion
he said
who was the greatest american president
after world war ii
and i thought a bit and i said well it's
hard for me to choose
it perhaps it was eisenhower
perhaps it was truman
and it might have been kennedy he said
oh no you're all wrong it was richard
nixon richard nixon was the greatest man
and he
made the opening to china
he said nixon is my friend we correspond
i said you do oh yes he said we exchange
letters regularly about once a month
and he sends me all his books
and i said you read them oh yes he said
i haven't translated into chinese and
i've read all of his books he's a very
wise statesman
i said well do you send him some books
he said oh yes i sent him things which i
think
he would be interested in reading
and there i fell down as a reporter i
failed to ask him what books he sent to
mr nixon and i haven't gotten around to
asking mr nixon but i would dearly like
to know whether nixon read the books
that uh
that uh
who you buying sent to him were you
under the impression that huyabang was a
disciple of deng xiaoping
he was very much a disciple of deng
xiaoping but he was a the kind of a
disciple who has his own uh category of
interests as well
uh i wouldn't say that deng xiaoping
necessarily shared all of huyabang's
tastes but he obviously
liked having an idea man an action man
with him to stimulate the ideas of
of of the elders who often were slow on
picking up on things
he shared a personality in a sense with
deng xiaoping because
while deng xiaoping has done some very
bad things lately in the connection with
the massacre
when he came into office in
1977 and 78 he was very much like
huyabank he was a young he was a older
man
uh he was in his early 70s but he was
full of ideas and full of energy and he
also was the kind of a man who might
leap out of his chair the chinese called
him the india rubber ball because he had
lost power so often but he always
bounced back up full of energy and went
forward to something else it was very
apt description of him and
i think he was exactly the kind of man
that china needed after the disaster of
mao and the terrible problems that the
country faced because he was bold and
daring he
he had imagination he was quite willing
to bring into china all kinds of
capitalist devices
devices from america from the west
anything which he thought would help
china
move more rapidly into the age of
technology
into the modern world as it was he
wasn't bothered by ideology or anything
of that kind his most famous statement
which most people know around the world
is that it doesn't
matter whether the cat is black or white
so long as it catches the mouse
and by that he simply meant
if it works we'll use it
because that's what's more important
than something which is written by marx
maybe a hundred years ago
harrison salisbury is here to talk about
his book and this is as of september 1st
in your bookstores both hardback and
paperback small question to you how come
both came out at the same time
well this was an instant book and
i don't know why the publisher brought
the two of them out together but i think
he wanted them both available because he
wanted this book available to the public
as quick as possible i wrote it very
rapidly
he published it very rapidly it took me
about a month to write it it took him
about a month to publish it and i think
that set some kind of a record in
publishing and this book is 176 pages
long that's right
i want to
talk about a personal thing with you
before we start off because one of the
things that
and the audience that reads this will
know this it's a little bit
fast-paced you takes your breath away
you wonder how can somebody go this fast
and go this many places and you and i
before we went on camera i asked you how
old you were and you told me that you're
80. that's right at 80 years old how do
you get the energy to do something like
this and this and by the way something
like this is being in
beijing in the middle of all this well
uh i don't know how i got the energy to
do it but i think it's probably
because it's what i've been doing all my
life i have been
i started out in newspaper work really
as an agency reporter and you may know
that agency reporters have to write very
very rapidly i mean they don't often we
didn't even have time to write the story
we had to dictate it without even
writing it
i've always been used to working hard
and working very rapidly and perhaps it
becomes a ingrained after years and
years it becomes a habit and i think
it's a good habit and it served me well
i've written a great deal in my life
and i couldn't have done it unless i
wrote rapidly it has its disadvantages
there are
errors in uh in tiananmen diary i don't
think any there are no errors of a major
consequence but lots of little facts and
names spellings and things like that
it was not well proofread it wasn't time
for that and i didn't have time to look
everything up i just zipped it off and
here it is in your hands you start off
in the very beginning and it says aboard
jal flight i assume that's japanese
airlines number five new york to tokyo 6
p.m june 1st 1989 did you know something
was up
did you know something was up before you
left oh no i didn't know anything was up
i mean i in general as everybody did i
knew that there was a
certain amount of um tension in beijing
the students had been in the square
since the 15th of april or shortly
thereafter but i wasn't going over there
to have anything to do with them i was
going over
to work on a documentary
which would
deal with the 40 years of the people's
republic which
will be celebrated the 40th anniversary
celebrated on the first of october and
it was sure coincidence that we in the
japanese crew that i was working with
chance to arrive in beijing on the 2nd
of june
which was less than 48 hours before
the troops moved into the square uh it
did position me in a in room 735
on changan avenue in the beijing hotel
which has a view right up to the square
which is about a block and a quarter
block and a half
to the west but i didn't have that room
because i thought something was going to
happen out there that i was going to
look at it just chanced
to put me there with a front row seat on
what turned out to be one of the big
stories of
certainty of the year how did it come
that nhk the japanese television network
had hired you to do this documentary
well they began talking to me about that
about a year ago
and the reason that they came to me
was that
i am very well known as a as a
specialist in china i've just done a
great deal of work
in the field and they knew of my work
they wanted somebody who had some
background who could treat china from a
historical basis they didn't want simply
spot reporting they have very good
reporters of their own but they wanted
somebody who could put it in historical
perspective who could understand or try
to understand and explain
how the people's republic came into
being where chairman mao came from the
red army and what they hoped to do
in that period of time
and also to to enumerate their
achievements and also their failures
because there were failures right along
with their achievements certainly
and i think that's why they came to me
and we discussed the general ideas and
the outline of this
documentary and found that we had in
general the same
ideas about an approach i had
i had a free hand really to what was to
go into it and all the rest of it
and so we formed a partnership and i
drafted an outline of
the important events which i thought we
should show photographically if possible
and the kind of scenario and chronology
we should go through
and we came to a general agreement and
we did a great deal of work on that
documentary before going to china we did
the historical research which i did
and they sent in camera crews to
photograph certain geographical
locations and places in china which were
important to this story
uh we did interviews with me in new york
uh on some of the historical aspects of
it and
and
also interviewed a few people in the
united states
did all of this preliminary work
and had about a month of shooting to do
in china
this was going to be divided into into
three parts
they wanted to take some background
shots of myself in gentleman square we
had no idea that other people would
already be shooting in that square
before we got there
we
intended to interview
about a dozen very important chinese
officials not necessarily in position in
power at the present time some of them
who had a historical role in the
people's republic but some of them were
contemporary
we expected to photograph an interview
xiaojiang he had the man who was
dismissed as party secretary he had
agreed to be interviewed and he was
number one on our list
and then we had a certain amount of
works to do out in the countryside of
locations
where i wanted to go and and
explain the significance for example of
the great wuhan bridge which was the
first great
industrial accomplishment of the
people's republic the first monument as
it were to the building up of china
which had been done with the aid of the
soviets and so we wanted to go there and
i wanted to stand out beside the bridge
and tell the history of it and what its
significance was
things of that kind that we were going
to do so we had these three different
components we thought it would take
about a month
and we by coincidence arrived in beijing
before just before the
the
troops
opened fire on the students in the
square
and the whole city was taken over by the
so-called martial law troops and
and dissolved into fighting all over it
was impossible of course to do any work
in beijing and we had to change our
plans uh in accordance with the actual
situation did you ever complete the
documentary yes the documentary has been
completed and it's not been completed
the way we envisaged it
since we never did get to interview the
people in beijing and we never did get
to take pictures of me in tiananmen
square that is not of that kind we have
one there's one on the back of that book
but it is with the with the student
demonstrators which was not intended to
be in in the in the 40 years of the
people's republic at all
but we did put together a picture after
we
left china
a couple of weeks after going in because
we found it impossible to do the work
we'd come to do
after we left china and came back we
immediately put in a new request with
the chinese for permission to return
when conditions were more peaceful and
we'd be able to do the work that we
planned originally
and
alas we did get permission finally to go
back but too late actually for the from
the technical side from the japanese
they couldn't
they could not
uh go in and take more pictures and get
them into the documentary and use it
before the first of october as they
planned
but in anticipation that we might not
get back
we
made a substitute picture as it were we
took all the material we had and we had
some beautiful stuff from the chinese
historical archives the movie shots of
mao coming into beijing 40 years ago and
things of that kind
and this has been put together in a
documentary with commentary by myself a
lot of it is what you call in the
language voiceover since i'm not on the
spot they have photographs and i
comment on the photographs in that
matter
and
the kind of the form of the documentary
has been changed it was going to be 2
one or two hour shows it's now been made
one
hour and a half
presentation
it's pretty good not as good as it would
have been if we'd had the chance to do
all we wanted but it will be presented
to be presented on the i think on the
28th of uh of september in
1974 you retired from the new york times
after how many years
well i'd been in the times for about 25
years
uh roughly what have you done for the
last 15 years besides things like this
well i in the last 15 years i have
written a great many books and i have
i have traveled very extensively in both
russia and
and china i devoted myself much more to
china than to russia in that period of
time
because china has sort of come front and
center
as it was even before that time i was
spending more of my time on the on the
chinese side and on the russian side
i suppose i've written let me see i've
written two books of memoirs
i have written uh the long
the long march the untold story which
was the uh the story of mao's
six thousand mile
uh
marwa's mario was a retreat from
chongkai shek's forces with his red army
uh 50 years ago which
gave the red army and the whole chinese
communist movement its
its form and its strength and it went on
from that in a few years to take over
all of china with my wife we went
over the whole route a very rough back
country in china
and i wrote a book about that the first
time that it had been treated in that
manner that book incidentally became
it did very well in this country but it
became a number one bestseller
in china and it made me very very well
known in china because
practically everyone uh certainly among
the literate or the intelligence or the
military or the students has read
the long march
it was it and lee iacocca's books were
best sellers the same year
interesting
interesting conjunction of chinese
tastes
and
that probably is the most important
thing that i have done since my
retirement
as as history how many times have you
been to china oh in in the last uh 15
years i suppose i've been to china about
a dozen times
usually for periods uh never for less
than six weeks and often as much as four
or five months and when you write and i
know this is a quickie but when you
write how do you normally do that is
there a certain time
normally i do this i i
have a project in mind you take the long
march which is a good example of it
and i have done my research in this
country which is
in the case of the long march and so
very little had been written about it i
read literally every single word in
english that had been written about the
long march i interviewed in the united
states
those americans who
had some peripheral connection with it
who knew the leaders of the march or
something of that kind
i i read up so that i knew
who were the figures in it who were
still surviving i wanted to talk to
and indeed i sent into the chinese a
list of about 40 people whom i wanted to
interview
little did i know that on that list of
40 people about eight of them were dead
but that was simply because they their
deaths had not been reported in the
american press
and
most of those people had been in prison
i might say too so i went to china with
a pretty good working knowledge of what
i wanted to find out what were the
controversial aspects of that march i
knew exactly where they went and was
going to follow the route all the way
along with the exception possibly of a
few places where the army doubled back
and forth over the same territory i
didn't see
i didn't see any need to be literally
follow every little mile that they
followed
and
i was dependent of course on the chinese
to make the appropriate arrangements to
enable me to go to these territories
since the areas were all closed normally
to foreign
travel and foreign correspondents
and
i got that and before i before i went i
had
the assurances from the chinese that i
would be able to do all the things i
wanted to do since i had been
[Music]
making requests and importuning them for
literally a dozen years
on this project they knew very well what
i needed and i said i'm not going to go
until we have this all in line and we
did
the result of that was that
that i spent in china
two and a half months
tracing the route not on foot as the red
army went but by jeep and
sometimes by mule and other other
conveyances sometimes by foot but not
very far
and i interviewed all of the
surviving important people who were on
the march
or got at second hand a picture of what
they did and i was able to get into the
chinese archives they were very good
about that in digging out archives for
me
i rejected their their research many
times because it was not it was not
complete it was inconclusive or is
propagandistic
i think i gave them a pretty good lesson
in what
an american newspaper man or researcher
expects by way of facts
at least i was told this by the chinese
that they'd never
confronted the
necessity of finding out exactly what
had happened they'd taken the word of
somebody that this had happened to that
it happened it was a a difficult process
you take notes as you go or you take
notes as i go along
i don't use a tape recorder as most
people do these days except in
exceptional circumstances where
extreme precision is is needed on names
or dates or places or something of that
kind and i'd and i'm afraid that i might
possibly make errors of that kind
uh in this case i didn't use the tape
recorder very much i didn't need to
but i wound up with let me see i wound
up with probably
12 or 14
standard size notebooks
very closely written of notes
the principle task for me with those
notes the first thing to do i
each evening after taking my notes for
the day i would sit down my old 1942
remington portable typewriter and
transcribe those notes because my
handwriting is very poor
and unless i write
transcribe
very quickly i'm very apt
not to be able to read my notes
so i've learned to do this arduous as it
is after a day's long day's work to sit
down the diaper i still do that
and i keep them in great detail i if i
encounter
circumstances along the way along the
path i keep notes in the form of a
journal or a diary
and the techniques which i used
for note-taking and all the rest are the
ones that are used in the tiananmen
diary they're literally a literal diary
let me show the audience uh how you've
done this book for instance this is day
four and as you can see here it's
beijing hotel
4 30 a.m is this an exact account of day
to day that you wrote on the spot or did
you write this when you got back no it's
an exact account of what i did on a day
to day and hour to hour and minute by
minute there is one slight uh amendation
when i copied my notes off and i did
copy these notes off in the manner i
described quite rapidly because of
wanting to be able to read them
i i i hadn't originally intended to
write a book or anything of that kind i
was just transcribing from my own
interest or what i might use them but i
quickly realized that indeed this would
be a book and it was had a historical
interest
as i transcribed them in on evenings and
i had
i had an evening in canton and one in
hong kong and one in tokyo on the way
back and then that long train ride to a
plane ride
when i could use my typewriter
i transcribed about half of my notes and
i put in
identifying material where i mentioned a
name i identified who it was and things
of that kind
other than that there is no change i
didn't i didn't
put any
later wisdom into the notes any mistake
and apprehension or understanding is
right there in the book
corrected later on in the book if i was
able to correct it
the only material written after the
period of the 13 days
came when i had completed the
transcription and i added a final
chapter of interpretation in which i
tried to explain as best i knew how
uh what had happened why it had happened
what were the political factors involved
and what the consequences might be
see here that uh that chapter i think
was called a fortnight later that's
right
uh were you pretty tired when you got
back i was very tired but when i am
writing something like this it
stimulates me a lot and i am i find that
i can go on working for a good long time
the adrenaline begins to flow when you
got back and where is home
home is up in northwest connecticut in
taconic connecticut right up at the
beginning of the berkshires and when you
write what time of day do you write the
best
well i think i write the best probably
between 4 am and 7 am when i'm writing
something like that
i get up
quite early when the household is all
asleep and i have
three or four hours of uninterrupted
work
before breakfast
and
then after that i can read over what
i've done and
make the corrections and editing and
then go ahead and plow forward and do
what little research i may have to do to
write a coherent narrative and that's
more or less the pattern that i followed
on this book
what do you hope this book will do
i hope that it will it will give people
a precise
account of exactly what happened at
tiananmen it will give them some
understanding of the forces at work in
chinese society which in the first place
produced
the emotions and the drive that
propelled the students into what
amounted to a crusade as they would have
put it to improve their government not
to
not to rebel against it or anything else
and the forces it stimulated within
chinese society and the political
structure
which
instead of adapting itself and taking
the opportunity to move with the
students instead rose up and crushed
them
in an effort to demonstrate that they
still have the power and nobody could
tell them
what to do i think it's very important
that we understand that because it's a
it this is a
benchmark in chinese history
as i understand chinese history and
contemporary history
under dung they were moving very rapidly
and very effectively
toward a new china a china which would
would cast off a great deal of the dross
of the old not all of it by any means
but it would move into contemporary
techniques and things of that kind and
take the first steps i so hoped anyway
on a democratic process
and i believe that the 10 years that
dung led china
on the program
of reform and opening to the west were
10 of the best years that china has had
certainly in the modern day
and then in one period of a few hours
this was blasted away
i don't mean that china is forever
halted by this of course not china will
pick up the beat but they it's it it
the tiananmen cost china a great deal
not only dung personally by destroying
his image to his people
but china in general because the
political and economic effects are very
great i don't believe anybody thought
what these effects might be but it will
be a long long time before china begins
to move forward again as she was moving
uh before that day and i think we should
understand that because
we're we're very apt to lose sight of
these things they get blurred over
as time goes on and the government has
made a great effort to try and present
an alternative version
that there wasn't any channel and there
wasn't any massacre that we fall all
lies on
students to some extent
and then two categories which i had them
define for me one are bad men and one
are bandits
and the students the bad men the band is
conspired in a plot so they say to
overthrow dung and overthrow the
communist party well there was no such
conspiracy and i think it makes it's
clear to anybody who reads that book
that there wasn't
we know what the students are the bad
men
uh as they defined it or were
bad men are people who recently have
been released from prisons
and who are capable of carrying out
criminal acts and some of the students
became bad men in the process of this
tiananmen affair the bandits were the
ones that interested me most
because
when when
chiang kai-shek
was struggling against mao and his
communists
he called mao
and the communist bandits and i wanted
to be sure that the present generation
of communists were using the same word
that
chiang kai-shek used when they talked
about bandits and sure enough they are
using exactly the same term
they mean a slightly different category
of enemy the bandits are hardened
criminals the ones who destroy state
property and
not likely to be students but they
sometimes are bad men bad men turn into
bandits and maybe students over a period
of time can do that
uh
well as you can see from my explanation
which seems
to me at least to be perfectly
ridiculous they've
they have a whole language which they're
using to construct an alternate
theory about what happened in 10 on men
as far as i know
jen and min
was the responsibility of the old man
and dung who ordered the army to fire on
the students and on the people in
in beijing
the only people who were manifesting any
any opposition to the government were
students the ordinary people of beijing
and there were around the fringes of
this
a few unemployed
youths they may be in the definition of
the government either bandits or bad men
i don't know how they define them but
they were unemployed because the
government couldn't find any work for
them and they joined in being idle they
joined in what was going on they didn't
play any important role in it
i think we should have all these things
clearly in our minds because there will
be an error
in which this will all be passed and
people say well what really happened
i mean did we have an exaggerated idea
did dan rather in his cameras give us a
picture that was false in some way
that's what the chinese are saying
uh i don't think he did i think he gave
us a very accurate picture of these
young idealistic young people
and he gave us at least a little glimpse
of the arbitrary action of which the
regime was capable when they pulled the
plug on his broadcast
and that was in a sense a small
forerunner of the kind of action they
would take when they would pull the plug
on the whole demonstration and tell the
troops to come in
and
blast their way through by any means if
you went through the book and
probably wrote down
the person's name that's mentioned the
most
it would just from my looking through it
it'd be charlotte
who's charlotte
charlotte is my wife and the reason that
charlotte is mentioned more often than
anything else in the book is in the
first place we're very close
uh we or normally when we go when i go
to china we go together it's um it's a
joint operation
and when we're in this country we're
together and constantly during this time
knowing how troubled she would be that i
was in
in what she would perceive a situation
of great danger in turmoil
i picked up the telephone which would
lie on the table of my my room wherever
i was in china and
they have a beautiful touch tone system
which was installed at great extents
they bought it from france at the
insistence of the chinese army so they
have good communication system and i
used it to call charlotte in taconic
connecticut and i would get through to
her in about 20 seconds
and i could reassure her that um
things were not as bad as they seemed
when she was looking on the tube and she
could tell me what was the latest being
shown on television in the united states
and keep me up to date with the image
that
the people in the united states were
getting what i was seeing only part of
with my own eyes when you got back did
you two sit down and
spend a lot of time chatting about what
you had seen versus what she had seen
yes we had we'd done it we we did that
but quite honestly we had done a good
deal of it all the way along because i
called her
every day and sometimes more than every
day and we traded impressions as we went
along
when i came back she gave me an overall
summary
of how it seemed to her how it seems
hurt friends and various points which
stuck in her mind which we hadn't
discussed and things which perhaps i
hadn't known about
one of the most interesting
ones of these was the following i
after i got out in the countryside and
left beijing was traveling in the
countryside i began to be more and more
aware of the element of xenophobia of
the effort that the government was
making to turn
the blame for everything on
foreigners and particularly the united
states
and this was a
exasperated by
the fact that we had given refuge in the
embassy to fangliji the famous chinese
dissident and for reasons i don't quite
understand that very name and that man
is anathema to deng xiaoping and the
chinese really were vibrating about the
idea of him being in
in the embassy and they were demanding
that he be released demanding all these
different things
and it occurred to me i knew that we
would not release a man that we'd given
political embassy uh asylum to
that the one thing the chinese might try
was to seize a hostage
and looking around the country uh
all the americans had left the country
by that time
uh very few uh people left in the
embassy
some
regular working newspaper men in
in beijing but i stuck out like sort of
like a sore thumb because i was very
prominent in china and i thought the
chinese would think well he's a very
prominent person why don't you grab him
and then we can work a trade i didn't
really want to be involved in anything
of that kind and i didn't say anything
to charlotte about this because i didn't
want her worrying about that
but lo and behold
she got a call one day from somebody who
wanted to know if she had heard anything
in the state department that i was in
some personal danger
she was very upset by that
and then that very evening
dan rather mentioned on the cbs
broadcast that the american
the state department is worried about
the seizure of a hostage
who might be traded off for family xi
so i realized then that this what i
thought was a vagrant thought in my mind
was one
which
which really uh was in other people's
minds and
one of the first things i did when i got
back to
taconic was to sit down with charlotte
and explain to her how this all had come
about and i didn't really know and i
don't know this day how the state
department got worried about that
question but i think it was simply using
the same kind of reason and logic that i
was using in analyzing the situation
what day did you leave beijing
i left beijing uh on the fifth of uh the
fifth of june what day was the attack
and the attack was uh the third and
fourth and where did you go when you
left well uh the first thing we had to
do was to get out of beijing which was
not at all easy because uh the beijing
hotel where we were was was surrounded
and barricaded we were really prisoners
in the hotel but we got a
a chinese driver who was very familiar
with the the little alleyways the
hutongs that make up the central part of
beijing we managed to pick our way
through those back alleys until we
managed to get a clear highway the
reason for the difficulty was there were
so many barricades across all the
streets and so much military activity
and shooting that we didn't want to
and the driver didn't want to expose his
car to it and we didn't want to expose
us to it we got out to the airport which
is deserted because nobody could get out
of the city and we flew down to wuhan
about a two hour flight out of
out of beijing and there we begin a trip
through the countryside which enabled me
to see how the people outside of beijing
were responding to the events
and whether indeed they knew what had
happened uh in beijing they had their
regular commercial service still
underway during this time oh yes yes
indeed
and um
there had been many rumors that the
the air service had been closed down
but it hasn't it
for the first time in all the years i've
been going to china i rode on a chinese
airplane that was not filled
the chinese airlines had a i think
a practice of not flying until they sold
every seat in the plane but they
couldn't sell them all now and what was
your reason for going out into the
country after
you'd been in beijing during this period
and did you take all your japanese
camera crew with you yes we went out to
fulfill the uh the countryside segment
of our uh our
our planned itinerary we went out to to
film in various cities that were
important to the history of the people's
republic
to interview people in various these
various locations
the first place we went to was wuhan
where the famous bridge across the
yangtze had been built
and
we found that wuhan had been the scene
of some very big
manifestations in fact they were still
going on when we arrived there there had
been
there had been
big demonstrations in wuhan on the very
afternoon and sunday afternoon after the
after the massacre already word had
reached
wuhan and the students had come out and
carried out demonstrations and large
crowds gathered
we went into the heart of town and found
that we could hardly get through the
shopping
center because there were four big
meetings being held by students and
there were big posters on the walls uh
telling about what had happened in
chiang min and listing the names of
wuhan students who had been killed in
the in the massacre
we drove out in the town and discovered
we bumped into a big funeral parade
coming back that had held a a ceremony
for the victims of chennai men and they
had these great big chinese
paper wreaths that they used for their
funerals
and there must have been several
thousand people in in that
and so we knew immediately that
that the people in wuhan at any rate
which is a great city of several million
people
knew all about
what had happened in the square and as
we went along deeper and deeper into the
countryside we found the same thing was
true
all of this had been gotten out the word
about what had happened there had been
gotten out by the students ahead of the
government propaganda this is before the
government began to claim that nobody
was killed there was no massacre intent
on men and so we then found
that people had already gotten the truth
in their systems and when the government
lies began to come out
they were taken as lies by the people
they didn't stand up and shout about it
but they knew perfectly well the
government was trying to put something
over on them and they weren't buying it
how did you stay in touch with the
outside world during that time well i
stayed in touch in two ways one by
shortwave radio i listened to the bbc
and the voa constantly and also my
telephone calls to my colleagues in
beijing
and my japanese
colleagues has called their
correspondence in beijing or in tokyo
and so we were quite well informed as to
what was going on and what kind of a job
do you think the bbc and the voa do
i think they did a magnificent job i was
i was utterly astounded
from the very beginning um at uh
let's say 4 a.m or 3 30 a.m on on
june 4th
i was in my hotel room and
changing avenue was dark i could see
movement there i could hear the shooting
from
tiananmen i couldn't tell at that moment
whether the troops had taken over the
square whether a battle was going on or
what and i flicked on
the voa and i got the last part of a of
a broadcast in which they were saying
the troops had come into into the square
and they had been firing as they came in
and a lot of people had been killed so
then i i could interpret what was
happening in the square
as the as the day wore on again and
again
when i was not clear as to what was
actually happening on the streets after
all i had limited vision
only down
a few blocks to the east and a few
blocks to the west
i would turn on the
radio or tv i didn't turn the tv the
radio to either a bbc or voa and see
what they were reporting and if on it
matched up exactly with what i was
hearing and seeing
i think they did a great job i don't
know anybody outside of the chinese
government who contends that their
reports were exaggerated in any way
sometimes they weren't entirely accurate
but you don't always have a hundred
percent accuracy in the middle of a
battle uh too much is going on
and in the early stages for example
uh they under-reported the casualties uh
that was that was we all did that i
myself estimated i couldn't believe that
more than 100 150 people at most have
been killed and i was astounded when i
began to hear reports of several
thousand but this was because i hadn't
realized how many people had been killed
by the armored columns as they
plunged into the city with their guns
going into solid masses of people and
literally blasted their way through
those crowds
after i had a couple of first-hand
descriptions
of what happened when the tanks and the
armored troop carriers came in then i
could readily see
why the toll would be as high as that it
uh it needn't have been but if you're
going to go in and you're shooting
you've got an awful lot of targets to
shoot at by the way when did you have
your first discussion that this was a
book i mean you said that you didn't
start out thinking about it oh well i
tell you i that came
the day after i got back to new york i
i uh called my editor
roger donald ed little brown and i said
i've got something to talk to you about
and he said i've got something to talk
to you about well it turned out we had
the same idea
tiananmen diary he didn't know i'd kept
a diary but he thought that a book on
this subject a quick book
would be useful and i thought i said
i've got it half written he said
wonderful we're going to make that an
instant book so we've never tried that
before but we're going to do it this
time because the interest is here we
want the book to come out while people
are eager to
know exactly step by step what happened
so i said fine
and i proceeded then
to complete the book which i had about
half copied i completed the book and
wrote the
the final chapter explaining as best i
could well i thought it happened and all
that
called up roger and he came down from
boston stopped off at taconic
and spent the day
editing something which i've never
handed an editor in my life this was the
raw copy i hadn't had it i hadn't had it
copied over i hadn't copied it over
myself it was full of interlining and
all the rest of it he said that doesn't
make any difference i'm a good editor i
can i can read all through all that and
he did and at the end of the day he said
fine it's a book
and i had answered two or three
questions and put little inserts in
he took it away
turned it into their copy reading
department
and
i believe the day after the fourth of
july was turned over to the printer and
we had bound books by
the fourth or fifth of august
and actual publication date was
september 1st yes publication was
september 1st
and
is it too late have things changed since
you finished this or do you find this
still relevant i think every word of it
is very relevant there are some things
which i've found out since which are not
in the book and i wish they were
more details of
how the troops
blasted their way in a little bit on the
political background a few little facts
here and there but there is nothing
wrong in the book the i think it has the
right
mood it has the right explanation for
why
the chinese acted as they did and i
think i have accurately portrayed
the response of the students and most
particularly of the people of beijing
and at no time during this trip did you
find yourself out of energy
by myself out of energy
you were able to deal with all this jet
lag and traveling and all this kind of
stuff i think when you have something
like this on your mind
and
when you're when you're really revved up
about something you it jet lag tends to
vanish i i can't recall a trip in which
i had less problems with jet lag do you
want to go back to china yes very much
so i um
i'm working on a much bigger and broader
project than chiang mai what i've been
working on for the last three years is a
book
on the dung shopping period in china
essentially
what has happened in china since mao
died
when did he die he died in 76 in
september
exactly
13 years ago uh this month and um he
left china in a dreadful state of chaos
dung came in and he put things together
and he got china going in a remarkable
way and he had 10 straight years in
which he did
he changed china in many ways
as it hadn't been changed in thousands
of years he brought prosperity to the
countryside by eliminating the communes
and enabling the farmers to go into
private farming and private business and
and make money
very good for china
and then this comes along
an unfortunate and contradictory
end really to his career
something which damages enormously his
achievements and it will take them a
long time to pick up on it all of that
goes in this book which i'm now writing
about a third of that book was written
before
jenna mindari
and i have i think all the essential
research for the other segments
which all been blocked out
last three years i spent an awful lot of
time in china working on this
but i should get back
and to take the temperature again and
make some political soundings so that
i'm a little bit more certain
of
the
direction in which china is is going to
emerge after dung
passes from the scene and hopefully get
a little clearer idea who his successor
may be
i'm not sure this is accurate tell me if
i'm misreading it you got a sense that
going into this whole experience of you
being over there that you thought the
students were going to win you come out
more pessimistic saying it may be a long
time did you change your view during
this yes i did very much so i thought
that i thought
from all i had learned before going over
there and indeed what i learned after i
got out it got over there in the short
period of time
that i had it looked to me as though the
students were winning or at least their
ideas were winning they didn't
necessarily have to have that dialogue
with the government they might not have
it but the government
which had the same general objectives
was going to be spurred and pushed along
in that direction by the student
movement
and this i must say
was the view of my chinese friends they
all believed that
extraordinarily and beyond their
expectations this was what was going to
happen and they were almost deliriously
happy about it
well as we know
i was wrong and they were wrong and it
all came to a bitter bloody end
and it's not going to be that way
the next round when it comes and i'm
sure it's going to come
with dong's death is going to be a
struggle of a different type it's going
to be led i don't think by students but
by adults probably by the people of
beijing i don't know who their leaders
will be they didn't have any leaders in
this
in in the tiananmen thing they were just
all of them out there but they're be
leaders
and the army will not be one unit as it
was supporting dong but probably
conflicting
uh generals and divisions
it may there may be some civil war i
don't know there may be some
splintering up of china at least
temporarily uh
reversion
i hope it doesn't happen but some of the
chinese think maybe a reversion to
warlordism or something of that kind
out of it all i'm sure there will come a
new china which will take up the beat
and continue to march towards something
better but it isn't going to happen
tomorrow it isn't going to happen two
years from now i can remember during the
june uh
the those days that you write about
a television reporter standing in
tiananmen square saying china will never
be the same again
this is before the military moved in you
think that the reporters were too
optimistic
and
do you think it ever will be the same
again
well
they're absolutely right that china will
never be the same again but that isn't
what they were thinking about they were
thinking that china was going to be the
new china that would follow would be in
the model
of what they saw in the student movement
and i remember very well dan rather
saying that i remember betty about lord
the wife of the ex-ambassador saying
words the same effect and i know many
people many china scholars in this
country
and
particularly a lot of chinese
students and and younger chinese saying
that
they were they were wrong about it how
can so many people be so wrong
well let me give you another thing
the cultural revolution which lasted
about 10 years and
embraced probably
well undoubtedly the worst atrocities
that china has ever seen and
the death of millions of people and
and the disgrace and murder of some of
our top leaders
when that was all over
mao dead dung in power
every chinese i spoke to of whatever
generation whether it was of dung's
generation or the new
youngster just out of school said we've
learned our lesson there will never be
anything
the lies the government is telling are
the same techniques which were
used in the cultural revolution how can
they how can people make these mistakes
i think
they're made because
they misread
some essential ingredient ingredients in
human character they misread
in particular what revolves around power
and the extent to which a man who has
power
would use whatever means at his disposal
to hold that power even at great cost
i see dung as having used the power of
the military in the force of the
military and the shooting down of his
own citizens as a visual and vivid
demonstration that he is still in charge
and he's able to run that country with
the help of the army in spite of
anything people say
he's not alone in that use of power to
hold power i think that one has to
understand that anyone
who has absolute power as it tends to be
true in a dictatorship like china or the
soviet union will in the end use that
power use the power of illegal to keep
his personal power he identifies with
his country
and we must remember that
here's what the book looks like it's
both in paperback and in hardback
little brown publishes it ten of men
diary 13 days in june by harrison e
salisbury our guest for the last hour
thank you very much thank you
harrison salisbury former new york times
editor and author of tiananmen diary 13
days in june it's published by little
brown and company for more information
visit their website at twbookmark.com
every weekend book tv brings you an
encore presentation of book notes on
saturdays at 7 pm and sundays at 11 a.m
east